I'll be fine
Hi my name is my waiting house Ryosuke on google
8 Today is android app quality guidelines
A lot of different qualities on that recently Google Android developer site
Guidelines have been added. Typical ones are
It's ui ux
General guidelines on goritin that are equally important
As google has published the guidelines recently, I have a background about that
I would like to have time to talk about various tips.
I am working with Android Developer Clock on Google
nice to meet you
Please
I would like to thank you.
It's getting tired so it's already summer, it's certain that it's summer and it's summer
Live
The players have a bit of trouble and that broadcast has been postponed but I did not
I think today is fine
Yes, but rather how to improve the quality of the app
By the way, it was introduced in the previous broadcast
I think there was an android design web page, but 8
That
More like a high check list than
If we recently issued the guideline from our company
Let's explain it one by one today, so it's a capital share
Yes, that's right
Well, what is really behind the scenes is the attraction of that end of the volume is the attraction of the app
I think that the part that is greatly affected is very large.
So, if you want those who bought the android terminal inexorably, you want that excitement
It looks like various application examples
You may think that it is good to buy the terminal ah by using the app already
How can that quality be achieved?
While providing information as much as possible from google, by all means to those app developers
We want to have them, but our application is expensive
Is it quite enough to differentiate itself?
That's pretty much compared to Seo's app, but I want users to be in this position
Because it will be easier to say
Even if it is better that the high frequency is high even by the factor of that differentiation, today
What kind of application is high quality while explaining the guidelines
One piece of piece that says the quality is getting higher
Items
While I'm looking forward to it, it's nice to see Mr. Matsui in Seoul explaining
I think
Well then you should go to the computer screen first of all
Or
Oh yeah Oh this is a little bit
First of all
What is displayed on the screen now
this
A section called Up Quality on Android Developer's Website
there is
In this section
So far there are about 3 big guidelines published by Google
One is core up quality
The other is tablet-up quality and the third from various users
For feedback
Well various recommended accidents about the response are introduced
The content of this is so diverse that today's Sawari's
Part i
I would like to introduce some cart big from core up quality
It's been done recently, hey, hey
Well, it's been a long time ago that it was released to the public first of all that head of this year
It may have been about
A section called Tablet-Up Quality has been added recently.
The
And this is Nex that we announced from that child
A terminal that is or is complicated to be a terminal of Las 7
Even in the market, the quality of tablet apps is becoming more important
This should be strongly guided by google
Well just before it's a tablet or something more basic than before
First of all, there are 6 core parts that you can put into kill each application
Let's think very much up-quality, so let's go first
Shall we
Click link
Yes I went, but this is a little smaller for those who are watching that broadcast
I think I see it by all means while looking at it secretly in the browser on hand by all means
But I want to talk about that little bit, so this guideline
Oh dear
Well, it is divided into some big sections, but the first big one
Section is visual design & user interaction
Here is a section in the section is almost already this Android design
Guidelines
Please be sure to comply with that.
Design guidelines in André as content
If it is this way of simplifying Junko with an explanatory note of feeling that points
Explanation that quality will be high
Well, I want to skip that detail today but it's coming out
There's a navigational taiko this is another moving landin Landon is Godzilla Gunn
Please take navigation as it is. I think that back button
Because it is controlled by default to all android terminals by all means, it is 5 pairs yes
I want to ask
Or when you press the home button, you should always return to the home screen
Wiper recommended Satation of customizing that home key
Hmmm I heard that this is that notification
I don't like being too noisy
Not many
Here's the part that you should take care of
It's an atmosphere that's a year old
That's right here, but it's important.
Russian birth
There is a function whose next big one is also block
It is a section called Hayano Yes that is functional it
Well, it's too common that only a little words are used, but I'm looking at the item or I'll hold the easy soil
I will try that
Perception is written in the textbook
Permission is as much as possible
Please make me angry with a few permissions
If you are installing the app, you
Well there is no permission
The country thinks that it is natural to be anxious when it is requested a lot unnecessarily
Anxiety Anxiety is also considered as a language comment
I wonder if it will be easier for me to go down, but I'm going to put the clock on my head
I mean not
After all perfume perfume this way also say that
Thinking thinks about mission
I am saying that the form of going to take is the best
Well, that's typical of the kind of permission that makes the user anxious
I'm reading through the contacts
That or when I read the system log
Make a Bubba Call here are you the te
It was once in the department that worked out the tax system for easy-to-understand explanations
It is also one way to write in the description and especially that one
Well if you need to exchange sensitive data dynamically while running
Take out the keg or do some explicit user relationship there
Android by making you care for such users
The app is for the user
I think it may be possible to use it newly
And next is speaking of installation location s 2 / card
Please tell me that this is that of people like that terminal
00:00 with internal memory and external stress
There is an area called internal storage and external storage
But this is a complaint when it comes to internal storage
There are many customers who rush into
There is a terminal in a limited memory, but it is yes by all means this is an app
Application android manifest.Iki another tree in xml
Just write me
If you have at least android 2.2 or more yes yes floor you want to ask
Is almost mandatory already, yes
And I will skip the screen a little
I'm wise lapping tigers
Let's go to preset or let's go from audio This is that
It is written in some detail, but simply speaking it does not sound at the time of the lock screen
Please
It seems that the lock screen and the screen hall that are exhausted will be life
Especially when it comes to game applications, it is often the case that you suddenly get surprised
When
I don't need the lock screened wood, so it's true how many times it is
so
It's a problem that you can hear the music on the lock screen in a moving ball.
Is the case I have ever seen a game
I went to the home screen to finish but my brother's music continues to sound and I live in the back
Do you say
Music will keep sounding when I try to the other application
I have seen a phenomenon that says that such part does not happen
By all means
I hope for consideration and think early
Yes and
It is this that it is written with that celebration graph ui bubble la fix
That's right as a recommendation for that
It is a part that the terminal will not be allowed to turn vertically or horizontally
This is that
In particular
Oh dear
It is expected in the case of tools based utility productivity based apps
There are more users
I think that the contents are pulling out the keyboard from the bottom with that ball head sideways
As there are three girls with such stuffy noses, in that case
It is very difficult to use an app that is only compatible with letters
Well, in the case of games, this is
It becomes a problem of the worldview
There is also a view of the world The part that thinks about the manga usage scene is that the user's usage mind
Of course there are of course there are also resource problems etc. I think there are various things
In the game again
Yup
I think it would be nice if you think, but it is compatible
Note
It seems that you say that is good
Yes next was up
This is a user upgrade. This is that simple.
Oh, for example I left the app and went back to the other apps and came back again
I see 3 that state is saved
I want to be able to resume properly
I can't see how well the game was saved to the US Army
It is a kind of feeling whether or not another consideration is recommended some kind of
Well, for example bluetooth or gps is a pretty area like
I'm using it
Appo For example, I went to another app that was temporarily away
Please turn off bluetooth or gps by all means when you say
I see
Imai I will continue to give you a column column It seems to be a better than even う
And again if you go back to the app and you have such a function that Tanaka-in needs
I think I say loveliness is the movement of that focus or activity
According to the life cycle of
Ask that management
I think if you
Yes and
Stabilized by the arrogance of Aikome with a sense of attention
Well, this is already very difficult to talk in a few minutes, so please put it together
Early up
Please make it fast and stable.
Yes I can only say so, but just
Well that's right after touching the screen, for example
For example, it is too late to make the user wait for 0.5 seconds or so
Less than 0.2 seconds
The response of the is generally expected, I would like a button
If it is troubled that loading seems to be different from woman by woman after pushing
I think that
The
Whether that ui's ui works crisply is an important part of quality
With the com pipe
Yes I think so by all means
I do not do the kind of thought with ui thread
If the user can tune the app until the last minute of the user, the action is
It is good for the user to put too much processing on where to wake up
It seems to imitate the action, and one more point regarding this performance, especially that one
Especially when you use web view, you can see the network after a touch occurs
It is no longer for you to go to
In the meantime, it seems that the food does not change at all during that time.
In the middle it's true
This is quite a user experience of that smartphone tablet
What
It's a shame that even though it's been years as an app, it's regarded as a sloppy love.
I think before that I think
Even if it is a hunger degree, let's read ahead with that part or use that kind of foot
Let me talk about that kind of thing when using u web fire
If you can make full use of it
It is a thing, and the change of the screen is already
I'm not saying that I'm switching the screen after the data comes, but I'm switching the screen before
5 behind me with something happening on the screen
That hurry to prepare the data If you don't let that kind of user wait anyway
Please ask for consideration
I think that I want to do it
Stability It's hard to explain again, but it won't crash or freeze
Don't do heavy processing with ui threads
Let's save memory as much as possible Oh, speaking of that wooden item is talking about Moon
I can not do it
Oh, yes
It is hard
It is such a basic thing but it is worthwhile to spend that time very much
When it comes to being loose, it's a child app that becomes quite fragile here
It exists in many
That day jua's ice te This is
Oh dear
Provide a very beautiful visual tailored to the screen resolution and discuss within us with shallow
When I see the app on the phone
Igor suddenly when I've got it in my place
There is a tendency for Jagi Jagi to enter
There is a tendency that there is a blurry part.
Ne
Even if the remodeling changes, the dark days are together
So by that
Well nexus terminal that we announced that this nexus 47 points
10 pro terminal is now 2560 pixels times 1600 pixels
The resolution has become-by all means such beautiful resolution
An expression that looks good
I think if you can all ask
Iida entering
I played Google Play Yoshitsuji Ahaa
Well I wonder if I would like to ask you right away
It's the same feeling as the last time, I've been talking about it so far
on google play
It is important to provide an app on top of the group here.
First one theme
Please be sure to follow the policy
Please have a goupe developer content policy
The content rating is also firm
Look at that rating of Joongsu Fine a 8 a
It is part of the first policy that you should paint well
so
Even if the eighth order is the detail
We're starting a blog post from us, but it's definitely a feature
It is a place that please put a graphic
feature Understand in simple form without too much clutter
There is a place that please do it easily
Well, the video that was a screenshot
Well here is actually quite inside, but with non android device
It is a video or screenshot
I would like to avoid as much as possible, but I often see it.
but
I can see it from const but I hope that you use good things here
It is a place called
Please make sure your mart user support is correct.
It is quite common to say that
that
There is a possibility that there is a possibility that the bug resulting from there is hidden, so overlooked
Please be sure to give support well without
It becomes a point
Well, so it's okay to have them appear on the screen of a couple of people
Hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm which is somebody about the other than that
Various know-how
Important to this Core Up Quality Guidelines
that
A lot of information is being provided
That little school
Has entered
Information provided by us
How about that reason Yosuk
It will be an idea
Why do you use this information for differences?
More
8 good good content quality is high
In the high-run attack can be high in the application
8 If the application for which the attack is high was extremely excellent content
At the same time, it is easy to reflect our features and such
It is called a guideline
In fact, I think that it is a turning point if it is in line with this double
Yes, so the quality way open
+ Marty small which is likely to be featured more easily
I'm going to Kouno
Such guidelines of strong control are explained in this guideline
I think it seems like I'm cutting it off to some extent
That feature is just one possibility, and I will never promise from that country etc.
It is not that I can do it
It is not limited to feature but it is ranking and search ranking etc
To the sky of such app itself to have you go up high in part
It may not be very important that you
It seems so quite that
Oh dear
I hope the device point that the user has can be expected to be high to some extent, but now
Some users have tablets like this in android
Well when there are some users who are playing phones
In what form do you expect each user to meet their expectations late?
After all
You will use points or both, and you will use that app when you like it
The user is more likely not to say anything
The higher the level of satisfaction, the more natural the number of Google Play stars will be.
If there are many behind, naturally it will be on the ranking, so the app
It's true when you stay in the terminal for a long time
Then, let's take a look like it's a good app
App users who will be loved by users for a long time, so it will be spread to everyone
It is fun and convenient to use
Yup, it looks beautiful
An application that Kimo day sun grass movement is also stable
That google play that
Ranking, search ranking and also our editorial conference this feature
I would like to make sure that I would like to raise the exposure at the editing conference as well.
I think yes if you can ask for an understanding
Is
Is it all right to ask questions?
Today's Seo is that it probably won't end with a little bit of anaha
I'm sending in the first part
I'm sorry that the screen subtitle is not riding with the first part
It seems that this is not all part 1
Which is the complaint that will come later from the actual user later on
It should be done in the same way with s whether it is sharpened to cope
Well, I think that it will be better to deliver at that next opportunity, but with the questions received today
Say
Wintering
Please wait
What is coming
There
Yaho
It is a chain device Wigsus
Hmmm, some of the abandoned holy cups
We have sent you
Get service as a service to listen to the user's voice service rod com 8
users voice. com is introduced, but similar service in Japan
do you have
I wonder if this can you start?
What does that mean to our two people or service?
Well for men and women, it's a service to keep in touch with the user
Well there is that user
In such a place that this developer is managed
Guide the user towards there eg complaint or bag direction
Become
If you post more and more feedback to users
In that day blocker from that
Well then, this has been cured, etc. This is under consideration, but it is like that
Interactive from the communication developer
Well there seems to be a place like saying that it is a comment bird
Hey
If you provide the functionality of this kind of interaction itself with google play
The schedule is
There is one right now, in the form of reply to comments, the constitution itself yesterday is in progress
It seems to be gradually expanded to developers
Unfortunately for those who still have c, there is no such c cedede, but it is very good at the examination stage
Only some people can offer that test
It is planned that there is a reply function to the comment behind, but this is gradually
that
It is possible to say that you do not want to expand the commissioner This is also one
So-called interactive interactive with the tool user
We are expecting to move into a green one
Yes
Next question
Are there any items that can not be released as an app without following the high strength guidelines?
Oh yeah
Well I can release this
If you dare to mention such a developer distribution
agreement It seems that it is a violation of the example, so-called policy violation
Is not this
Yeah I don't need a kid that's released and found that
There is one black star in this history when it becomes out of the Purpe
That seems to be left forever forever
If there is any such policy violation, that
It's like I want you to be careful, and it's love and visual other voice
The vertical and horizontal correspondence of the screen
For example, you can already do the publishing itself on Google Play
Right in that
Especially, for example, the way of music is strange
Even if the screen looks dirty depending on the correct terminal, it seems that the movement is slow in the first place.
Well released
If it is already done, the user of the article is sure to receive a comment
Well, it's up to the meloper to decide what time to fix
Well, at the beginning of the pilot phase, it has started offering to a few users.
Have you received that user cup from
I'm doing my best with Garr while receiving feedback
A child
Sometimes we sometimes see cases
It is the Diet, and then the next is the content that has been reproduced following the wide area guidelines introduced this time
Content that is particularly emphasized in the Japanese market
Or the difference between the situation in Japan and overseas
8 Japanese power
this
Japan's reaction is tough in response to customers, but it's tough to some extent Japan 0
If the lens comes out, it would be fine for both inside and outside of the country
content
When I make a tablet to see well, I suddenly go to the crowded place
It is true that there are many cases where the layout is broken.
There is quite overseas people corresponding to the tablet there
It is a part but I do
As for the guidelines described here, especially the border
What is the difference in the market?
I do not think so much
If you enter and say
that
I agree
In Japan, vertical scrolling in web games is rather popular, but it is more popular
It's hard to be accepted, right? Well now filler
I guess that's right
If you are an overseas user, that so-called i-mode culture game so far
Playing Culture or Playing Games There is no experience in playing games in i-mode
Suddenly
Users coming from smartphones to smartphones
Because there are many to say
There is not much culture called scrolling
I don't think it's true from the perspective of the game
Yup
That's about it, especially when it comes to guidelines
It's not that the difference is that it is a part of the taste of the sea drink line
Although I often say culturalization, I often use Asian people in the desk part
It seems that the lively screen is preferred
Western
That popular popular app prefers the app as clean as possible
In a way like
I think that is often said, but regarding that there of that android
The guidelines are neutral, so here are the different developer
We will enter if we can make a decision
Hmm
Well, that's the end of the question, but that's the one I said-
It's full of booboo and you just have to make some medicine.
Aringu from my google + page that I have been a nufu
It is not an official translation of Maa, but to Mr. Ando's kindness already
Thank you potato This quality guideline is very
User experience
It's also a manifestation of google's desire to improve as much as possible.
If you have a few of those apps, you should have that quality
Get in high praise of users in the quality part of construction community content in love
I always got what I think we always have, ー and Kyoko
You should talk to him something
Booboo is okay today, and I will talk about that series of children for a while
Well, I think if you let me talk about Eto'o on a basis like the basics of basics
By all means Well then today thank you for that 5 hours Today's broadcast is this
ibus it has become cold so please beloved everyone Thank you for today
I was sorry